foreign
capable of taking down entire armies all
by themselves these powerhouses are the
stuff of myths and legends are there
such extraordinary monuments of raw
power in our favorite pirate Saga to
answer that question we bring to you the
top 10 one-piece one-man Army moments so
hang on to your hats as we tackle these
mighty monsters
let's retrace our steps to the beginning
of the one piece story as Sir crocodile
the desert king kicks up a storm at
number 10 the first major villain to
cross swords with the straw hats the
former warlord of the sea makes his
appearance ironically as alabaster's
guardian angel he single-handedly saves
the citizens of the desert Kingdom from
looting Pirates fooling everyone with
his hero act with a pass cloaked in
mystery the enigmatic slick-haired mob
boss remains to this day one of the most
iconic characters in the series even
though this particular moment Miner
actually display the extent of his
powers we can assume that the Explorer
is no pushover not afraid to go
head-to-head with the likes of Don
Quixote doflamingo and Whitebeard
crocodile does hold his own
entire
University
[Music]
Zorro's annihilation of the Baroque
Works agents is an early example of his
Godlike swordsmanship and also serves as
a backdrop for his penchant for cursed
swords with no knowledge of haki and
without his great Blade's shoe suite and
enma the Brash young first mate still
gives us an extremely memorable
performance undoubtedly he's pulled off
way more unbelievable Feats since those
early days like slicing up kaido for one
but this incident in whiskey Peak
endures as a demonstration of his
reliability who better than the trusty
Mario mode to serve as the next pirate
King's right hand
[Applause]
speaking of one-man armies it's been
obvious that the main protagonist should
be able to pull off a daredevil stunt or
two and that's why at number eight we
have Monkey D Luffy as he Kos an army of
50 000.
foreign
making an unforgettable comeback after
the time skip Luffy gives us a front row
view of the incredibly rare conquerors
haki of course this isn't the first time
the young pirate has unconsciously
stunned an oblivious audience with his
intimidating Spirit as we've seen in
Marine foot and Amazon Lily but after
the straw Hat's humbling defeating
sambodi at the hands of Bartholomew
Kumar and Admiral kizarroof we see Luffy
brimming with confidence once again and
just like that he halves holy Jones's
staggering Army of a hundred thousand
fishmen winning the admiration of both
his crew and former shichibukai jinbei
it was this moment perhaps that put the
final seal on jinbei's Ultimate decision
to join the straw hats
yeah
number seven is God NL as he proves that
raw power matters more than numbers
foreign
devil fruit that allows him to use
control and transform into lightning NL
raised the bar as a villain very early
in the storyline if not for Luffy's
rubber-like ability the tyrannical God
would most probably have succeeded in
his mission to destroy the sky island of
Skype here nl's Swift victory over Zorro
and Nico Robin two of the more powerful
straw hats along with former God ganfor
and shandyan Warrior wiper is proof of
his almost Divine capabilities as the
last one standing Nami obviously doesn't
stand a chance against the death-defying
NL who can even jump start his own heart
given that the self-proclaimed God's
logia powers are on par with those of
the Marine Admirals encountering him as
a rookie pirate crew was surely a
terrifying experience for the straw hats
[Music]
our next candidate at number six is
former Marine Admiral aokiji running
circles around the straw hats
come on
[Music]
okiji is by far the most all about and
generous amongst the Admirals having let
Nico Robin Escape as a child but in this
brief Skirmish he leaves the straw hat
shaken to the core the Admirals are
hailed as the world government's
greatest military power and algiji shows
us why this reputation is well deserved
during the encounter he makes short work
of the monster Trio while the rest of
the crew can only just watch in horror
Luffy usually tenacious finds himself
entirely at The Iceman's mercy and is
spared only as a gesture of Goodwill
towards his grandfather Marine vice
admiral Monkey D GARP and that's only
after he and Robin find themselves
Frozen and left to die brutal one moment
and nonchalantly cycling off into the
Blue Horizon the next aokiji's actions
leaves his opponents and us in the
audience thoroughly confused a hard man
to figure out his desertion of the
Marines in decision to join the
Blackbeard Pirates later on makes this
walking blizzard and intriguing Wild
Card character
no
in the fifth spot our Gigi's fellow
Admiral kizaru makes a splashy Landing
in sambodi to humiliate the supernovas
and quite literally burst that bubble
the term one-man Army is perfect for
this towering light human who
incidentally has one of the most badass
character introductions in the entire
series confident of his abilities
gizarro deals with four of the notorious
rookies yurush battle Hawkins x-strike
and scratch man Apple all at once a low
gear user like RPG kizaru can transform
into light making him impervious to
gunshots he remains unscathed even after
Apple Cuts him to pieces as a parallel
for Hawkins creepy reanimation ability
kizaru is on a completely different
level with power similar to Eno the
momentum the Marine gathers as he moves
that the speed of light makes his
attacks that much more lethal and
inescapable strong enough to go
head-to-head with silver Raley's the
pirate King's right hand the rookies
naturally don't stand a chance against
the Admiral
[Music]
thank you
in the ongoing guano Arc that evokes Edo
era Japan with its Shoguns and Geisha
ninjas and Samurai Zorro's impeccable
Warrior Spirit steals the show in the
fourth spot similar to many Samurai
Ronin films this scene where sorrow
destroys a gambler's Den with just a
swing of his hockey imbued arm brings up
images of famous medieval Samurai
Legends and if that display of his might
isn't enough he goes on to Vanquish and
unruly mob of armed swordsman without
actually slicing them up the visuals of
the man cleaved in half might be
horrific but still managed to excite the
audience throughout the series zoro's
swordplay has grown in Leaps and Bounds
he sliced the tricky pika's giant stone
form in half in dress roster before
going on to become only the second
person to leave an indelible wound on
yonko kaido's impenetrable hide with
that said though it really makes us
wonder how much farther the green-haired
pirate has to go to finally surpass his
Idol mihork and claim his title of the
world's strongest Swordsman
you know
this top 10 wouldn't be complete without
at least another mention of Luffy so at
number three we have him knocking out an
army of Marines and Pirates all by
himself in the Paramount War
m
[Music]
the Marine foot Arc features more than
one astonishing Luffy moment including
his aerial infiltration of the Marine
Fortress and his Brazen challenge to the
three Admirals for the one that stands
out the most is his very first display
of conquerors haki with The
Executioner's blades inches away from
Acer's neck and the entire Whitebeard
Allied troops and Luffy's own Motley
Crew tied down attention is off the
charts and that's when the straw hats
Captain lives up to his Heritage of
being related to both Marine hero GARP
and revolutionary Army leader Dragon he
does this by paralyzing a huge crowd of
seasoned Marines and pirates with his
presence alone this moment which leaves
the bigwigs in attendance completely
stunned what what the [__] speaks
volumes of Luffy's potential and even
though the war ends in tragedy for our
hero his allies would certainly have
taken solos from this singular feat
which Heralds a new era for the pirating
world
[Music]
probably
a grudge match that takes the runners-up
spot as kaido accepts the challenge of
the Arca xia9 who've set out to avenge
their fallen Lord gozuki Odin after a
20-year wait in this fantastically
choreographed Samurai assault the nine
Avengers sadly lacked the power to
overwhelm the as your dragon any fight
with kaido in it is almost always a
one-man Army show in this one the
samurai might not pose much of a threat
to him but kaido acknowledges their
resolve and courage and fights them with
the respect they deserve this elevates
what would otherwise have been a
one-sided bloodbath suicidal at times
kaido's fascination with the glory of
death especially on the battlefield is
what sets him apart from other villains
making him an intriguing character study
amongst the yonkos we've come across so
far big mom is easily distracted while
Whitebeard was ill and quite old at the
time of his death so that leaves kaido
who doesn't really seem to have any
weakness more so against opponents who
aren't in the same class as Luffy but
then the road is long and we've yet to
see who else is left to challenge our
next pirate king
[Music]
foreign
so it's time to unveil our winner now
and it's the strongest man in the world
[Music]
Edward Newgate AKA Whitebeard making his
last stand at the Paramount war in the
most moving story arc in the long one
piece Saga might be its death
overshadows The Staggering destruction
that he leaves in his wake so let's take
a look at this Monument of a generation
of pirates long gone and pay tribute to
the force of nature that he was from the
moment he arrived on the battlefield
Gravely ill and short-handed compared to
the huge Naval Force standing in his way
Whitebeard demands awe and respect with
his devil full Powers he's capable of
unleashing seaques and tilting both sea
and land without these abilities and
despite his frail condition he can still
Bear Down on the Marines with his pure
physical strength but what makes him
memorable isn't just his power but his
modest attitude towards his crew each of
whom he considers his son uninterested
in the types of pirate king or finding
the one piece Whitebeard shows us the
importance of family with his honorable
Spirit he brings shame to the
underhanded tactics used by the Marines
ironically called the pillars of justice
and there lies the rare Legacy of a
truly great pirate
one piece
oh
and with that we come to the end of our
video it's a never-ending Journey with
one piece as we grow with the characters
Revel in their victories and mourn their
tragedies as we wait for more of this
tumultuous Adventure it's nice to
revisit these past events don't you
think so so if you enjoyed the video do
subscribe and leave us your thoughts in
the comments below till next time